[Música]
me va a retarlos y en realidad vengo a
afectarnos a todos nosotros en que los
programas tienen ciudadanos del mundo en
que cambiamos nuestra forma de pensar y
podamos enfrentarnos a este mundo de una
forma diferente cambiamos la perspectiva
quiero hacer un paréntesis y traer una
anécdota de los años en los que estuve
estudiando mi pregrado en cuba'
allí tuve la oportunidad de compartir
con más de 30 naciones
y es verdad mi universidad albergaba
casi 50 naciones de distintas carreras
que se daban en esta universidad pero
hay algo que marcó mi vida para siempre
y ellos y es cuando yo entendí qué tipo
de persona deseaba convertirme en un
futuro me puse esa meta
esta frase este evento que me marcó es
una frase que dicen los cubanos muy a
menudo y te dicen no cojas lucha por eso
mi hijo no cojas lucha con eso mi hijo y
básicamente está evocando que cada uno
de nosotros al momento de enfrentarnos a
un problema a una situación que está
realizando en ese instante trate de
encapsular salir marcar y encerrar sus
componentes emocionales que hacen que
reaccione de una manera para tomar una
decisión más inteligente no estamos
diciendo que los quite lo que estamos
diciendo es que reaccione emocionalmente
más inteligente para resolver el
problema hay un expositor que me encanta
de hardware se llama howard gardner y él
nos habló en su libro múltiples
inteligencias de siete inteligencias
dentro de las cuales enmarcados que no
las vemos en nuestro digamos evolución
educativa se trata de la inteligencia
intrapersonal y la inteligencia
interpersonal a qué se refiere cada una
de ellas la inteligencia intrapersonal
hacia adentro se refiere a que podamos
conocernos saber qué tipo de personas
somos cómo reaccionamos en cada momento
de nuestra vida en los eventos que nos
encuentran nuestra vida entender esas
emociones y tratar de modificarlas
positivamente es decir para beneficio
nuestro y de con quien nos estemos
enfrentando la inteligencia
interpersonal se refiere a aquella
inteligencia con la que vamos a trabajar
con otras personas
viendo quién es que hace cómo reacciona
qué es lo que está pensando antes de
para poder que en conjunción encontrar
un punto en común y poder abrir las
puertas a recibir un conocimiento
hoy día les traje algunos elementos mi
compañera de viaje si me ha acompañado
bastante tiempo y básicamente esta
mochila viene siendo cada uno de
nosotros que estamos en esta sala todos
nosotros en el momento en que estamos
emprendiendo nuestro viaje de vida somos
una mochila donde vamos cargando proceso
a proceso sistema sistema experiencias
que hemos vivido en el pasado
conocimiento que hemos recibido en el
pasado
métodos ideas y acabamos un paréntesis
para que les mencione tres conceptos que
nos van a ayudar en la charla el primero
lo encontramos fácilmente en google
sistema sistema ordenado que se rige
bajo un conjunto de normas
no nos dice si es positivo no nos dice
si es negativo si evoluciona o se queda
estático si es obligatorio o es opcional
pero sin embargo nos dice que es un
conjunto que tiene ciertas normas todos
y cada uno de nosotros estamos
enfrentados día tras día a distintos
sistemas
el sistema hogar el sistema trabajo el
sistema barrio el sistema ciudad país y
no necesariamente bajo las reglas y
normativas legales que están
trascendiendo a nuestro entorno
constantemente también están las
normativas religiosas culturales grupos
políticos pensamientos deportivos y
muchos más el segundo concepto estamos
hablando de entropía para aquellos que
lo conocen la entropía es la magnitud
que mide el grado de desorden molecular
en un sistema
vamos a abstraer nos vamos a este
escenario que a muchos nos ha debido
pasar el padre el hijo el hijo está
echado en su cama en su cuarto y el
padre entra en su cuarto y ve que el
cuarto es un desastre un desorden bajo
los conceptos del padre de armonía del
hogar y pide que haya un cierto orden al
evaluar el punto focal padre está viendo
que ese sistema tiene un alto grado de
entropía
en cambio desde el punto focal hijo que
sabe dónde tiene las cosas dónde puede
encontrar las cosas donde las desea
tener y cómo las va a ser para
utilizarlas tiene su sistema controlado
de otra forma con un mediano o bajo
grado de entropía los dos puntos focales
ven el mismo sistema pero evalúan que la
entropía es diferente
usted ha dado en el mundo debe entender
cuál es el nivel de entropía que existe
al sistema que se está enfrentando para
que viene el tercer concepto vamos a
hablar de catalizadores es un elemento
que entra en una reacción física o
química para acelerarlo para frenarla lo
que yo desee es que estamos
catalizadores positivos aceleremos sin
mezclarse con la reacción química que
está existiendo
este es el objetivo de un ciudadano del
mundo
llegar a ser agentes de cambio que
aceleren este proceso de cambio sin
dejarse arrastrar por aquellas normas
que rigen este sistema que es son las
cuales lo ha motivado a cambiar a
evolucionar
volvamos al caso de la mochila
necesitamos nuestra mochila cuando
estamos yendo de viaje y si tenemos
buenas prácticas de viajero la vamos a
evaluar durante tres momentos al inicio
al medio y al final al inicio porque voy
a agarrar y ver qué es lo que me sirve
de todo lo que yo estoy viviendo para
cargar e irme de viaje me voy a la
piscina por ejemplo me llevaré sandalias
short una toalla me voy al bosque me
llevaré zapatos de trekking una gorra de
ala ancha bloqueador solar ropa liviana
cuando nosotros salimos de viaje en este
gran viaje de vida debemos evaluar y
sabemos que estamos cargando los
conocimientos para enfrentar este viaje
de vida
segundo punto de evaluación cuando
estamos en pleno viaje y evaluamos que
cabe en esta mochila y que ya no cabe en
esta mochila algunos elementos que se
arruinaron que ya no sirven que
perdieron valor para nosotros lo mismo
pasa con nosotros en nuestro viaje de
vida deben haber elementos y conceptos
que debemos saber discernir evaluar
evolucionar sacar quitar de nosotros
como mochila de vida tercer momento de
evaluación cuando volvemos del viaje y
sacamos la mochila y abrimos a la
familia a los amigos a la enamorada a la
pareja y les decimos he adquirido esto
he conseguido esto he vivido esto con
esa misma pasión los ciudadanos del
mundo debemos enfrentarnos a decir te
traigo esto
mira esto evaluamos esto
con esa pasión que permitirá que el
resto captura tu conocimiento segundo
elemento lo ha notado algunos lo deben
conocer otros no no lo sé
tiene un significado y el significado
para mí personal evoca un sistema
informal de educación un sistema
informal de educación que lo que hace es
sembrar semillas de valores en niños y
jóvenes para ser hombres de bien en un
futuro les cuento algo más todos los
presentes en esta sala están cargando
una pañoleta hoy porque porque todos
somos producto de enfrentarnos a
sistemas que han grabado en nuestro chip
personal valores nuestra casa nuestro
equipo deportivo nuestro colegio nuestro
trabajo nuestra pareja nuestros hijos
nos han enseñado en distintos sistemas a
los cuales nos hayamos enfrentado
ciertos valores para que para definir el
tipo de persona que quiero ser que debo
ser por qué por qué definen mi forma de
reaccionar y mi forma de accionar de
hablar de ser ante cualquier sistema que
me enfrente y el problema que enfrente
este sistema
me enseñaron responsabilidad con un
valor con un texto que nos decía
mientras vivas bajo mi techo cuantos lo
han vivido
o por qué no el cristianismo que nos
dice tenemos nuestra
nuestros 10 artículos 10 mandamientos o
la filosofía budista que nos habla del
ser y la naturaleza
o por qué no en el imperio incaico que
tenían sus propios preceptos que en ese
mundo
y lo que hacían todos ellos evocar
ciertos niveles de valores que se
grababan en el chip personal de cada uno
de nosotros pero somos nosotros los
únicos responsables de hacer que este
sistema de valores evolución y cambie
crezca hay una frase que allí me encanta
mencionar y es la de albert eisntein que
nos dice somos arquitectos de nuestro
propio destino solo nosotros vamos a
definir aquello que realmente haga que
construyamos nuestro ser o podemos
recibir todo lo que viene del entorno
pero somos nosotros quien decide lo que
va a construir nuestro ser y si sabemos
evaluarlo sopesar lo priorizar lo nos
estaremos convirtiendo en una persona
capaz de sentirse ciudadano del mundo
otro elemento que les traigo es este
bichito tecnológico
antes era muy difícil teníamos rollos de
fotos de 24 12 36 fotos y hoy en día
podemos abocará acá infinidad de fotos
verdad nos vamos de viaje y este señor
no puede faltarnos y le tiramos foto a
todo lo que se encuentre pero cuál es el
concepto de tirarle foto a todo lo que
se encuentre
vamos grabando vamos capturando momentos
especiales escenarios especiales
personas especiales aquello que causó
algo dentro de mí para que merezca valga
la pena guardarlo dentro de mí y tenerlo
como un recuerdo como algo que voy a
revisar añorar atesorar dentro de mi
viaje vida lo mismo nos pasa a todos los
seres humanos a todos los que estamos
acá vamos capturando vamos recobrando y
vamos levantando conocimientos emociones
sensaciones y valores que los queremos
atesorar y guardar
segunda función que tiene este señor en
10 centímetros más menos
tenemos el conocimiento del mundo me
enfrento a un viaje quiero saber dónde
quiero ir por donde voy que voy a
encontrar qué recomendaciones tengo
etcétera
pero está en mi validar y sopesar el
conocimiento que estoy adquiriendo acá
nos enfrentamos a una sociedad
globalizada con la posibilidad de tener
el conocimiento en un solo bolsillo
pero con el riesgo de caer en un
desconocimiento globalizado hay entre
una vez más la actitud de un ciudadano
del mundo es el responsable de validar
sopesar este conocimiento y en función a
que lo haya validado poder transmitirlo
tercera función de este bichito el
momento en que llegó a casa empiezo a
distribuir por redes sociales mandar a
la madre a mi chica a mis hijos a quien
sea todo lo que yo haya recobrado en mi
viaje lo mismo hacemos todas las
personas en el momento en que salimos de
casa mi viaje vida día salgo y recobró
algo capturar algo llego a casa te
cuento y se hice no hice
cuando estamos hablando de conocimiento
debemos hacer exactamente lo mismo pero
de forma responsable validar este
conocimiento una vez validado
distribuirlo tenemos ese deber de
distribuir este conocimiento para que el
cambio suceda para que podamos realmente
convertirnos en catalizadores positivos
nelson mandela nos decía el conocimiento
es el arma más poderosa que podemos
tener
finalmente quiero que retrocedamos un
poco en el tiempo cuando nuestra
profesora de literatura lenguaje nos
hablaba del proceso de comunicación y
nos decía que había tres componentes el
emisor el receptor y el mensaje hoy en
día nos enfrentamos a una sociedad donde
el emisor ve al receptor con el mensaje
cápsula do nos enfrentamos al receptor
que ve al emisor con el mensaje
encapsulado qué quiere decir esto vemos
en el mensaje un rostro una reacción una
acción antes de leer el mensaje vemos a
la persona evaluamos si esa persona va a
ser que yo crezca no crezca meme bokeh
emociones ira alegría sentimientos
y un ciudadano del mundo lo que debe de
hacer es encapsular estas emociones
sacarle el rostro al mensaje buscar el
mensaje que me está llegando analizarlo
y en el momento que lo haya analizado
ver si lo capturó para después
transmitirlo pero no con un rostro tener
la posibilidad de aislar este
pensamiento de quien viene de dónde
viene y a quién va porque es de ida y
vuelta
y saben qué barreras están ahí presentes
el respeto
y la tolerancia
si nosotros realmente queremos
convertirnos en ciudadanos del mundo
debemos encontrar los canales de
comunicación que permitan evocar respeto
el respeto entre los dos individuos que
se están encontrando en ese momento en
ese proceso de comunicación en ese
puente donde está pasando conocimiento y
tolerancia
levanten la mano todos miren sus dedos
ninguno son iguales
todos los hombres en este mundo ninguno
son iguales pero sin embargo van a
cumplir una función van a estar
presentes para una acción las manos son
acción
pero para poder entendernos entre
nosotros la barrera ya no es geográfica
para viajar para conocer
para conocer la barrera solamente son
dos conceptos respeto y tolerancia y a
esta fórmula hay que sumarle voluntad
tener la voluntad de hacerlo sí cuántos
de ustedes creen que pueden saltar esta
barrera respeto y tolerancia gracias
[Música]